it seems to me that the way that you
fortify your faith in being and in life
and your own existence isn't to try to
convince yourself of the existence of a
transcendent power that you could
believe in the same way that you believe
in a set of empirical facts I don't I
don't think that's the right approach I
think it's a weak approach actually I
don't I don't think that the cognitive
technology that I don't think that's the
right cognitive technology for that set
of problems you know that's more
technology that you'd use if you were
trying to solve a scientific problem
it's more like it's more something that
needs to be embedded in action rather
than in stainable belief and the way
that you fortify your faith in life is
to assume the best something like that
and then to act courageously in
relationship to that and and that's
that's tantamount to expressing your
faith in the highest possible good it's
tantamount to expressing your faith in
God and it's not a matter of stating
well I believe in the existence of a
transcendent deity because in some sense
who cares who cares what you believe I
mean you might in Oh about but but
that's not the issue it's not the issue
the issue it seems to me is how you act
and I was thinking about this intensely
when I was thinking about Nietzsche and
Dostoyevsky because of course you know
that Nietzsche was the philosopher who
announced the death of God right and who
was a great great critic of Christianity
at vicious critic of institutional
Christianity in the best sense you know
and he announced the death of God and he
said that we'd never find enough water
to wash away the blood it wasn't a
triumphant proclamation even though it's
often read that way and don't niches
inclusion from that from the death of
God the fact that our ethical systems
were going to collapse when the
foundation was pulled out from
underneath them
he believed that human beings would have
to find their own values to create their
own values and there's a problem with
that because it doesn't seem that this
is something Carl Jung was very thorough
and investigating it doesn't really look
like people are capable of creating
their own values because you're not
really capable of molding yourself just
any old way you want to be like you have
a nature that you have to contend with
and so it isn't a matter of creating our
own values because we don't have that
capacity it might be a matter of
rediscovering those values which is what
human was attempting to do now and and
and so I think Nietzsche was actually
profoundly wrong in that in that
recommendation I think he was
psychologically wrong now you know
Dostoyevsky wrote in many ways in
parallel to Nietzsche was a great
influence on Nietzsche their lives
parallel each other to a degree that's
somewhat miraculous in some sense it's
it's quite uncanny Dostoyevsky was
obviously a literary figure well whereas
Beecher was a philosopher a literary
philosopher but still a philosopher and
Dostoevsky wrestled with exactly the
same problems that that Nietzsche
wrestled with and but he did it in a
different way
he didn't literary manner and he has
this great book and The Brothers
Karamazov and in that book there's a
hero of the book is really a lyosha
who's a monastic novitiate a very good
guy kind of not an intellect not an
intellect but a person of great
character you know and but he has a
brother Ivan who's his older brother
who's a great intellect and and a very
handsome soldier and a brave man like
Dostoyevsky's villains Ivan isn't
exactly a villain but that's close
enough
Ivan or Dostoevsky makes his villains
extraordinarily powerful so if dustiest
he's trying to work out an argument he
he clothes the argument in the in the
flesh of one of his characters and if
it's an argument he doesn't agree with
and he makes that character as strong as
he possibly can as strong and as
attractive and intelligent as he
possibly can and then he lets him just
have out her and so Ivan is constantly
attacking Elly OSHA and from every
direction trying to knock him off his
perch of faith let's say and elosha
Alyosha can't address a single one of
Ivan's criticisms and and he doesn't
have the intellect for it and and and
Ivan has a devastating intellect it's
devastating to him himself as well what
happens in the brothers karamazov
essentially is that the Alyosha
continues to act out his commitment to
the good let's say and in that manner
he's triumphant it doesn't matter that
he loses the arguments because the
arguments aren't exactly the point the
arguments in some sense are a side issue
because the issue is and this is the
existential issue the issue is not what
you believe as if it's a set of facts
but how you conduct yourself in the
world